is it something that you want to direct
as well i've gone back and forth on
whether i actually had to direct it or
not let's just say you're the director
let's just let's not hand over the reins
just yet all right here we go i'm
destined daniel [ __ ] and i'm here
chatting with daniel hanno hi daniel
hi i'm rj daniel hannah i go by daniel
and i'm a 2021 nickel fellow we're
talking about all things writing and
namely his nickel winning script shelter
animal which i loved so much about a
female prison inmate who begins working
in animal shelter in order to gain
parole dust and daniel [ __ ] is a
filmmaker i really respect and kind of
inspired me to enter the competition
welcome daniel how you doing
i really loved your script by the way i
really loved it those characters just
like came alive i fell in love with them
i've always found that tragedy or
difficult dramatic moments are often
kind of the best time to interject humor
when things get really dark that's
typically when the jokes start to fly
what's kind of like the stages of grief
after you get those notes
the grief is probably when you feel like
you have something that's really working
and it's not translating i have never
written something in solitude and found
it to be
ready to go and shoot i need the
reflection of other people's opinions to
show me what's working and what's not
this script i worked on for a long time
and i did a short film and rewrote it
after working with actors and that
process really made me realize how much
extra stuff was in there in the future
that i didn't need and what the real
heart of the story was
i have that tendency to when i'm
starting to write a feature i just think
like how the hell am i gonna fill 90 to
120 pages and i just start putting more
and more characters and ideas and
locations for me almost always the
rewrite process is about simplifying
simplifying amplifying something that i
forget again every single time i start a
new project
yeah
i think in every single movie that i've
done there is a scene that was one of my
favorite scenes of the movie
on the editing floor the most fun scene
to shoot the actors were on their a game
everything seemed to be working about
the scene except that it wasn't
necessary in the movie and it wasn't
working
i've often found that it was a necessary
scene to shoot for the actors to
experience for all of us to experience
you know you started in an indie space
and obviously working on a bigger canvas
now what's it like as an artist
navigating that from a process
standpoint i don't see a huge difference
between short-term 12 and
marvel obviously there's bigger toys
there's more people but you're still
just sitting on a set looking at a
monitor and you're seeing one shot that
you're trying to get right and then you
move to the next one i said no to a lot
of things that some people would have
said you're crazy at the time that i
said no to them
i find that for me
being completely myself in a pitch and
not trying to sell myself not trying to
do what i think the other people want
may not land me the job every time but
it does weed out whether or not i should
be doing this with these people anyway
and when i look back at those no's they
defined me just as much as the things
that i said yes to
is it something that you want to direct
as well it is you know i've gone back
and forth on whether i actually had to
direct it or not let's just say you're
the director let's just let's not hand
over the reins just yet a little
premature
congratulations on a really beautiful
script i enjoyed it in so many ways
thanks so much and thanks for reading
and taking the time i really appreciate
it all right daniel talk soon
you